You probably know me,
if you know me at all,
as someone who does this.
[CELLO NOTES]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
There has come to us
a young man, aged seven,
bearing the name Yo-Yo Ma.
I've been playing the
cello for over 60 years,
so I should be getting
it right, by now.
However, is that what
I'm trying to do?
Am I trying to get it right or
am I trying to find something?
[MUSIC PLAYING]
This is not an
ordinary MasterClass.
I really don't like
to tell people things.
So I hope you won't
expect me to do that.
But during our time
together, we're
going to talk about what
creates magical moments.
That magic is something living.
And to me, that's
the essence of what
I try to do in music,
transmitting something
so it lives in somebody else.
[CELLO]
At one point, I had
the audacity to think
I could play a perfect concert.
I was in the middle
of a concert and I
realized everything's
going perfectly well.
And I was bored out of my mind.
That was the moment that
I made a fateful decision
that I was actually
going to devote
my life to human expression,
versus human perfection.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Music connects people.
You're sharing
something with others.
You're almost like the
scientist for the inner soul.
The whole act of
life is a balance
of unbelievably
intricate forces,
of which music is a subset.
I'm Yo-Yo Ma, and
this is MasterClass.
[MUSIC PLAYING]